mesdames et messieurs bonsoir le temps
se gâte par-ci par-là nouveau décidément
il n'y a pas moyen de fixer le soleil là
où il devrait être
la nuit dernière en alsace il est tombé
des hallebardes et dans la région de
saint louis entre mulhouse et bâle donc
plusieurs communes ont été noyés en
quelques heures sur une hauteur de pluie
d'un mètre et demi dont un maître par
dont l'un 6 juin c'est déjà beaucoup
avant d'en venir à la politique
française et aux grands dossiers
internationaux
nous commencerons par le sport en effet
il est rarissime qu'il y est en 24
heures une telle série d'événements
sportifs de premier plan
les finales des internationaux de tennis
la finale de la coupe de france de
football entre monaco et orléans
le prix du jockey club à chantilly pour
désigner le meilleur poulain de l'année
la fin du tour d'italie cycliste avec la
victoire de bernard hinault et le départ
de la course transatlantique en
solitaire
angleterre/etats-unis celle qui se
disputent une fois tous les quatre ans
et que remporta la dernière fois eric
tabarly
cette année tabarly s'est démis l'épaule
mais son public sera présent grâce à
pajot 89 bateaux ont quitté les côtes
anglaises d'après midi rendez vous dans
trois semaines à newport
un reportage de gilles cozanet c'est à
11h ce matin que les 91 bateaux
participant de la transat anglaise sont
sortis 2000 bedoch un débat 5 rue du
port de plymouth 91 concurrents prêts à
affronter 5000km d'atlantique nord un
océan toujours redouté pour ses
violentes tempêtes le prao de nicolas
clifton réputé pour sa rapidité
c'est un bateau calqué sur les pirogues
polynésiennes il sera pas tous les jours
à l'aise il sera peut-être à de ceux qui
progressent sur courir les accidents
matériels ont en effet commencé et deux
heures avant le départ la victime
florence arthaud dont le masque à 102 à
la sortie du port la nuit précédente
elle avait pourtant changer tous ses
haubans alcan en ce moment par tous les
moyens possible d'en trouver
repartir le retard qu'elle va ainsi
accumulé justifie sa détresse et c'est
là c'est la loi difficile de la course
une course que jester connaît bien il a
participé à toutes les éditions de la
transat son skipper mike which he sait
qu'il ne gagnera pas mais il illustre au
mieux l'esprit originel de la course
un homme un bateau et l'océan à l'autre
extrémité des monocoques celui d'olivier
de kersauson qui par son trop
d'illusions son bateau et puissant conçu
pour les mères les plus dur n'est pas
assez long pour concurrencer les
meilleurs trimaran à 15 heures heure
française le départ est donné par le
comité d'organisation de la tronche ap
le royal western yacht club
plusieurs centaines de bateaux de
spectateurs sont venus accompagner les
concurrents et spectateurs qui avait été
discret sur les quais sont venus en mer
par milliers sur toutes sortes dans bach
à sport du ferry-boat au canoë kayak
cette multitude de bateaux est sans
doute à l'origine d'un autre accident
qui a obligé tom grossman de favori de
la course pour les bookmakers anglais à
rentrer au port pour réparer à des
flotteurs de son trimaran et entre eux
et le vent à ces fables cet après midi a
permis aux trimarans de prendre tout de
suite le meilleur eric loizeau que l'on
voit ici
michael burch eugène riguidel et nikkei
prenant tout de suite la tête de la
course mais derrière marc pajot qui au
dernier moment a remplacé eric tabarly
l'hydrofoil qui n'est pas officiellement
dans la course a en effet littéralement
laissé sur place ses adversaires avec ce
bateau tabary aurait pu remporter la
transat pour la troisième fois
temis demain bjorn borg tentera de
gagner roland garros une cinquième fois
et sera opposée gerulaitis vainqueur
hier de commerce
aujourd'hui samedi c'était la journée
des trois finales doubles messieurs
vainqueur à maya puisse terre états unis
double mixte des tchèques lutte contre
des américains mais ils on sent pas un
set partout et 5 53e
simple dames chris evert lloyd a
remporté une nouvelle fois la timbale
les commentaires des athlètes
virginia rouge ici au service la
roumaine semble crispé habité de
surcroît par le complexe chris evert
excellente attaque quant aux et chic
temps d'exploiter son coup droit tourne
fréquemment son revers bref se bat sur
toutes les balles pourtant rien n'y fait
chris everglades joue très long sur le
revers de la roumaine lui interdit tout
monté au filet la prime d' accélération
en coup droit
chris everglades services et balle de
match regardez
voilà c'est sévère à venir roland-garros
en 74 75 79
elles vont porte ici sa quatrième
victoire dont aux dépens de virginia
roddick vainqueur en 78 en l'absence de
chris et à bernard hinault ajoute chaque
saison à son palmarès une victoire d'une
telle portée qu'il peut d'ores et déjà
être considéré comme l'un des plus
grands coureurs cyclistes de tous les
temps et dans la série des champions
français il prend la suite des frères
pélissier de bobet anquetil et le
poulidor bernard breton d'yffiniac côtes
du nord a remporté aujourd'hui le giro
le tour d'italie
succédant au palmarès des victoires
françaises jacques anquetil en 60 et 64
aujourd'hui bernard n'a pas remporté la
dernière étape du giro en circuit sous
le dôme de milan
il a fait attention dans ce prime d'un
peu tout fait mais il ne termine maillot
rose avec près de six minutes d'avancé
sur fa leeds a de plus il a réussi à
conquérir ce qui n'est pas chose facile
la sympathie des tifosi les fanatics
italien très exigeant et un peu chauvin
mais les voilà qu'ils ont adoptés
hinault dont le prénom ils ont raclé
sommes tout à fait tard et alien bernard
hinault bernard hinault maintenant
bernard hinault va tenter son troisième
tour de france
monsieur giscard d'estaing a présidé ce
matin aux invalides de la cérémonie à la
mémoire du soldat inconnu d'indochine
dont la dépouille doit être inhumé à
notre dame de lorette dans le pas de
calais aux côtés du soldat inconnu
d'afrique du nord au cours de la messe
dans la chapelle saint louis
monseigneur vanel vicaire aux armées
avaient rendu hommage à ce symbole des
60 militaires français créé en indochine
puis devant le cercueil drapé de
tricolore est placé au centre de la cour
d'honneur le chef de l'état a lu un
message aux armées dont voici un extrait
qui es tu dans quel village dans quelle
ville
as-tu appris l'histoire de notre pays
quel est le paysage de la lointaine
indochine que tu as regardé pour la
dernière fois et qui était la dernière
image que tes yeux pouvaient recevoir
l'union syndicale des magistrats tient
depuis hier et jusqu'à demain son
congrès à pau on ya beaucoup parler
aujourd'hui du projet du garde des
sceaux connu maintenant sous le nom de
sécurité liberté un reportage de notre
envoyé spécial dans les pyrénées
atlantiques
claude sérillon groupes aux noms c'est
définitivement non au projet sécurité et
liberté du garde des sceaux
tant pis pour la tradition modérée de
l'union syndicale des magistrats
ici à pau dans ce palais de justice ce
sont à la fois à des juristes des
citoyens mais des militants syndicaux
aussi qui ont tenu à dire bien haut leur
opposition au texte de monsieur
peyrefitte
c'est un danger grave pour les libertés
un danger pour la dignité des juges
expliquera l'ancien président de l'union
syndicale monsieur brun chevelle chacune
des interventions a relevé l'absence
totale de concertation l'atteinte au
droit fondamental de l'individualisation
de la peine
les risque d'élimination des juges
d'instruction même si quelques-uns des
juges présents ont exprimé leur crainte
d'être pris en flagrant délit de
politique plutôt que de syndicalisme un
risque à courir selon la majorité des
membres de l'union syndicale car le
gouvernement s'intéresse trop à la
justice et dans une direction qui ne
leur plaît guère vous avez entendu des
interventions à notre congrès et vous
avez constaté que nous nous exprimions
praticien en technicien du droit
monsieur peyrefitte d'ailleurs en nous
communiquant l'exposé des motifs de
cette loi nous a invité un grand débat
national nous ne faisons qu obéir à son
injonction
nous savons très bien que nous ne sommes
pas là pour faire la loi mais est en
charge et de l'impliquer c'est à dire de
lui donner sa portée de la mettre en
application nous pensons avoir notre mot
à dire
nous ne sommes pas certains d'être
entendu mais nous avons le droit d'être
écouté ceci dit tout ce que nous pouvons
dire c'est que sur le plan technique
juridique sur le plan en particulier de
la procédure pénale
ce texte recèle de nombreux dangers je
dirais même qu'il est porteur d'
insécurité juridique
signe des temps aucun représentant du
ministre de la justice n'est intervenu
au cours de ce congrès il est vrai que
les magistrats de l'ue sm revendique
désormais avec force leur autonomie de
pensée
plusieurs représentants d'organisations
professionnelles des métiers de justice
sont venus dire leur sympathie afin de
défendre une certaine morale une
certaine éthique judiciaire commune
faisons tout pour transformer les
lenteurs de la justice dira un
intervenant
mais n'abandonnerons pas notre code
pénal simplement pour aller un peu plus
vite
l'union syndicale des magistrats ainsi
tenté à pau d'affirmer une identité
syndicale sans pour cela rogne et son
attachement à une justice qui évolue qui
imagine le droit et des libertés
nouvelles en démontrant à l'opinion
publique que le bon ordre de la cité est
mieux sauvegardés par un système pénal
nuancé que par une répression implacable
à la suite des incidents qui les ont
opposés à la police il ya deux jours
lors de la manifestation des médecins
environ 80 nos confrères photographes
caméramen ont créé un comité de défense
qui travaillera en liaison avec
l'association nationale des journalistes
reporters photographes cinéastes et avec
l'union syndicale des syndicats de
journalistes santé un médicament
stimulant les défenses naturelles de
l'organisme mieux tolérés et moins
toxique que la chimiothérapie semble
apporter une amélioration dans le
traitement à long terme des cancers du
sein c'est ce que montrerait l'étude de
300 malades traités depuis sept ans à
l'institut gustave roussy de villejuif
par le docteur fanny et jean lacourt le
produit de synthèse utilisée s'appelle
paul biya paul y eut il s'agirait de six
injections intraveineuses
à une semaine d'intervalle avec des
résultats dit on très satisfaisant
revenons-en à la politique
raymond barre était aujourd'hui à tarbes
l'invité de nos confrères de radio monte
carlo
il a été amené à parler de son maintien
au poste de premier ministre
dans les mois à venir et ce à la suite
de la lettre que le président de la
république lui a adressé hier et qui
fixait le programme d'action du
gouvernement jusqu'à la fin de la
présente année
légitime east et je respecte les
institutions de la vème république le
président de la république nomme et met
un terme aux fonctions du premier
ministre quand il le juge nécessaire
donc je sais que certains s'afflige du
fait que pour il semblerait que je sois
reconduit évoluerez de sept mois le
microcosme et dans l'affliction
mais en ce qui me concerne là je
considère que je suis la disposition du
président de la république à bagnolet
près de paris conseil politique du cd
est au centre des démocrates sociaux
l'une des composantes comme l'envi de
gdf son président jean le caennais s'est
attaché dans son discours de clôture à
apaiser les craintes de ses amis au
sujet de la politique étrangère de la
france on panier de critiques ce fut le
cas pour les jeux olympiques telle ou
telle situation comportement du
gouvernement français il faut avoir un
regard sur l'histoire et sur le
déroulement prévisible d'événements sur
l'avenir est considéré que sur
l'essentiel
la france a une politique d'indépendance
il appartient que cette politique
d'indépendance accuse renforce fortifie
les liens solidarité qui doivent s'unir
aux pays européens les dirigeants des
radicaux de gauche tiennent aujourd'hui
et demain leur congrès dans un grand
hôtel parisien
l'une des questions posées c'est la
désignation officielle du candidat du
mouvement aux présidentielles de l'année
prochaine un commentaire de jean louis
de seine
le mouvement des radicaux de gauche
c'est la pm la petite et moyenne
entreprise de la vie politique française
cette petite phrase de michel crépeau le
patron de l'apn en question explique le
peu de moyens dont dispose la émerger
explique aussi la timidité apparente qui
est propre à toutes les petites
formations pays pourtant pourtant il ya
aujourd'hui le manifeste radical
discuter et amender ici tout au long de
cette première journée de ce 6ème
congrès national 132 pages qui répondent
à 12 interrogations cela va de l'école à
l'écologie en passant par
l'administration et l'information 132
pages de critique mais aussi de
suggestions concrètes
car si on peut lire des affirmations
comme l'état udf c'est l'état eu des
airs empire on découvre également au fil
des pages des propositions qui
surprendre les radicaux de gauche
propose de dissoudre les crs pour manque
de contact avec la population de
supprimer les prisons pour les remplacer
par des institutions de réhabilitation
peut fermer définitivement les portes du
ministère de la justice pour confier ses
attributions un conseil de la
magistrature élu par les magistrats
eux-mêmes de réduire le mandat
présidentiel à cinq ans mandat
renouvelable une seule fois
enfin d'instaurer la proportionnelle
dans les élections et la
décentralisation dans l'administration
bref un panorama complet de la france de
demain une france idéale revu et corrigé
façon émergent
cela dit ce congrès avant tout un
congrès de tactique politique car s'il
ne fait aucun doute ici que michel
treppo sera réélu demain président du
mouvement
il ne fait aucun doute non plus qu'il
sera également désigné par son parti
comme futur candidat à la présidence de
la république quitte à devoir revenir
dans les mois qui viennent sur cette
décision faute de stratégie
après avoir durement négocié avec les
socialistes en le ralliement des troupes
radical qui sont toujours bien ancrée
sur le terrain dans la vie politique
française
de nombreux journaux des démocraties
populaires publie aujourd'hui en
première page de message de
félicitations à georges marchais à
l'occasion de ses 60 ans est la preuve
de moscou écrit par exemple le site
hommage aux camarades marchais qui donne
toutes ses forces pour le renforcement
de l'influencé du parti communiste
français
fin de citation ces commissions
marchette fête son 60e anniversaire nous
avons entrepris une série de portraits
des personnalités politiques françaises
qui pourrait être candidat aux
présidentielles
après michel rocard il ya une dizaine de
jours et avant michel debré prévu pour
bientôt sur votre écran voici
aujourd'hui georges marchais tels que
l'abus jean-michel mercurol en franche
comté
incontestablement georges marchais
cultive son image
officiellement il ne s'agit que d'être
présents côté des travailleurs
en fait la machine est lancée qui doit
propulser georges marchais courant des
vedettes dans la bataille électorale des
gens ils sont contents le
secrétaire-général du parti viendra leur
région ils veulent me serrer la main
event des autographes
je ne je n'ai aucune raison de la
refuser je crois que ça témoigne que
contrairement à ce qu'on dit d'ailleurs
l'ambiance est bonne dans le parking
voilà pas un meeting au parti communiste
ou les disques ou ne soient
minutieusement préparé mais georges
marchais démontre quelques fois qu'il a
le talent de sont écartés et la passion
de convainc jeudi que ceux qui tiennent
ce langage pas de politique pour les
travailleurs et tous les maires se sont
d'aider ma mort ce sont des démagogues
et e croyez moi ils ne savent pas ce que
c'est que la misère
je suis plus ou moins agressif selon mes
interlocuteurs il est évident que quand
je parle de la situation des
travailleurs des luttes et bien je suis
sans doute plus mordants parce que parce
que les sucres l'air comme le sont les
travailleurs eux-mêmes meilleur l'envers
halléguen garde cette ville qui est la
mienne et qui me conduit à voyager à
travers toute la france a rencontré les
travailleurs manuels et intellectuels à
discuter à m'entretenir avec eux
approfondir la situation dans les
différentes régions dans notre pays me
donne une connaissance toujours meilleur
toujours plus approfondie de ce qu'est
la situation française n'a tourné des
grandes régions de bruyère et bien
lancée chez les communistes après la
lorraine après belfort c'est
l'automobile ici à sochaux avec une
cible le pouvoir qui est giscard
d'estaing lui-même son frère olivier
giscard d'estaing et administrateur 10pm
france de gypse et j'en passe
sa soeur c'est tout un programme
elle s'appelle en effet isabelle foule
que de lasteyrie de saillant de combat
nombreux sont les parieurs antigua qui
disent il est notre île et des normes
c'est certain georges marchais ne
négligera aucun argument devant son
public pour sa première campagne
présidentielle
joint de tous les registres ironie
écoute griffe simplicité et gentillesse
le secrétaire général du pcf paraît déjà
tout à fait à l'aise dans la peau du
candidat qu'il sera le 12 octobre
politique encore aujourd'hui et demain
se déroule à saint denis près de paris
la fête organisée par l'avant-garde le
journal de la jeunesse communiste depuis
hier soir plusieurs centaines de jeunes
gens et de jeunes filles ont donc
convergé vers saint denis en provenance
de plusieurs régions de france
dans ce qu'ils ont appelé une marche de
colère il s'agite au premier chef d'une
fête dans la rue et à leurs thèmes des
débats se déroulent en temps plusieurs
impressions de la fête
la défense de l'emploi la formation
professionnelle les luttes étudiantes et
la défense de l'esprit bref la défense
nationale est à l'ordre du jour pour
monsieur bourges aujourd'hui à toulon la
sécurité de la france doit être assurée
face aux menaces que certains états
pourraient éventuellement faire peser
sur nos intérêts
bonjour j'ai insisté sur le renforcement
de la flotte française déjà doté de
moyens puissants at il rappelé la france
d'ailleurs à l'heure des grands choix de
défense les discussions sont centrées
autour du service national et de
l'emploi de l'armé nucléaire tactique
notre confrère me quotidienne paris
écrit ce matin que nos savants sont sur
le point de maîtriser la technologie
nécessaire à la fabrication d'une bombe
à neutrons d'une très grande puissance
et à capacité stratégique le pays serait
bientôt en mesure d'exploiter l'un ou
l'autre des effets d'une explosion de la
bombe à hydrogène la chaleur le souffle
ou les radiations et selon le quotidien
dans un premier temps la france pourra
produire une arme nouvelle coupe capable
d'aspergés comme disent les spécialistes
de neutrons une zone de 30 kilomètres de
diamètre
l'armée est ainsi une vocation non plus
tactique mais stratégique évidemment
c'est très technique ce que j'aimais
antenne 2 vous propose pour ce mois de
juin plusieurs réflexions sur la défense
ainsi mardi dix des antennes de midi où
irait monsieur alexandre sanguinetti
ancien président de la commission de
défense nationale
le surlendemain jeudi 12 le général de
la garde chef d'état major de l'armée de
terre le lundi 16 questions de pain sera
consacré à la défense en général
sommes nous prêts et d'en antenne 2010
le 20 juin les représentants des quatre
grandes formations politiques répondront
à nos questions sur tous les thèmes
concernant la défense
demain lundi nous passons à l'étranger
les électeurs italiens vont aux urnes
pour renouveler les gouvernements des
régions et des municipalités ya cinq ans
les communistes avaient conquis
plusieurs villes importantes
quelle sera leur score cette fois ci il
s'agit certes d'élections locales
mais le parti communiste italien leur a
donné un sens politique en demandant
c'est ainsi la démission du premier
ministre monsieur cossiga pour avoir
protégé le fils d'un ami de démocrates
chrétiens inculpé de terrorisme alors
cette affaire influence-t-elle des
électeurs victor vraiment notre
correspondant permanent en italie s'est
rendu en cale à cozens les
automobilistes font ce qu'ils peuvent au
carrefour
aucun feu rouge ne fonctionne dans cette
ville de 110 mille habitants ils ont été
installés par la précédente municipalité
démocrate-chrétienne les socialistes et
les communistes ont sans doute jugé
entre temps que les feux rouges et est
une entrave à la circulation
j'étais dans l'italie du nord et j'ai
bien vu que les feux rouges qui
fonctionnent sont très utiles utilise 6
me les démocrates chrétiens font un gros
effort ils peuvent espérer reprendre une
mairie qu'ils ont dû laisser à la gauche
il ya cinq ans ici comme ailleurs en
italie
mais s'il est facile de dénoncer cinq
années de gestion municipale rouge
il est plus difficile d'expliquer le
nouveau scandale national
le chef du gouvernement aurait favorisé
la fuite du fils d'une personnalité
démocrate chrétienne recherché pour
terrorisme
à rome les communistes veulent mettre en
accusation devant le parlement
le président du conseil francesco
cossiga pour avoir protégé le fils
terroriste d'un ami démocrate chrétien
alors il est intéressant de savoir dans
quelle mesure cette affaire énorme va
avoir une influence sur les élections
locales
et si par exemple ici à cause n c'est
une petite ville de la calabre
les électeurs sont intéressés par ces
jeux politiques
romain le notable démocrate chrétien qui
a des allures mussolinienne par le vent
à peine 2 cocig il sait très bien que ce
sont les problèmes locaux qui intéresse
les électeurs de caussens
on n'a rien construit ici depuis cinq
ans la ville est sale la circulation est
de plus en plus chaotique
il n'ya pas de feux rouges les
transports fonctionnent mal mais surtout
et c'est scandaleux pour obtenir un
emploi il faut avoir la carte du parti
communiste ou du parti socialiste
en cinq minutes pas plus la tribune
démocrate chrétienne est devenue rouge
le bilan de la gestion municipale n'est
tout de même pas complètement négatif on
a fourni des engins très pratique pour
nettoyer les rues à cause ans
c'est la municipalité qui vous a donné
cet engin oui c'est un programme de
l'administration de l'administration
rouge de l'administration municipale
qu'il y ait des rouges des verts ou des
jaunes
c'est tout de même la municipalité de
gauche qui a eu l'idée de modifier les
trottoirs pour les voitures d'enfants et
les handicapés les démocrates-chrétiens
répondent les trottoirs sont tout neufs
on les a faits pour les élections avant
les élections vous les communistes vous
dites aux jeunes qu'ils vont donner
beaucoup à la gauche
après les élections vous nous traiter de
terroristes et de drogués les communes
risque organise des débats avec les
jeunes dans la rue il y a des problèmes
ce jeune héros ou non à voter dans sa
part réalité comme l'appelle avant ou la
vie politique c'est beaucoup plus faible
que dans les femmes dit il y aura ou non
au sionisme très diffuser ou non et je
crois que ce problème des jeunes quand
on se donne une idée de ce que
pourraient être ces élections locales
il y aura une forte abstention les
communistes pourrait perdre des voix
chez les jeunes et de toute façon la
mise en accusation du président du
conseil francesco cossiga ne suffira pas
à ébranler la démocratie chrétienne qui
pourrait bien reconquérir des mairies en
afghanistan l'armée de l'air régulière a
bombardé l'année dernière plusieurs
concentrations de rebelles dans des
villages de montagne par ailleurs selon
les organisations rebelles et des
voyageurs arrivés en inde les troupes
soviétiques subi raids en afghanistan
des pertes de plus en plus importante
espagne après les déclarations monsieur
giscard d'estaing sur la nécessité d'une
pause dans l'élargissement de la
communauté européenne
la plupart des partis politiques
espagnols réservent aujourd'hui leurs
critiques de la france et souligne la
nécessité de poursuivre les négociations
avec tous les membres de la communauté
marguerite yourcenar le grand écrivain
français récemment élu à l'académie
française a reçu hier aux états unis
la rosette d'officier de la légion
d'honneur sonar au nom du président de
la république et en vertu des pouvoirs
qui nous sont conférés
nous faisons un fichier la légion de mer
eh bien mon neveu n'aurait certainement
jamais d'effet car je me sens prêt
pacifistes et l'épée est un objet qui me
paraît assez ridicule
porté par mois et peut-être même portée
par une femme je ne sais pas pour les
femmes et les taris tu vois ce la
coupole
a certainement gérer certainement faire
un discours de réception est
probablement sous la coupole jeudi
probablement que ça se pourrait se
passer en petit comité mais ce sera sans
doute sous la coupole
à quel ouvrage travaillez vous en ce
moment à un ouvrage sur un moment ils
vont pas tout à fait un roman
trois longues nouvelles qui s'appelle
comme l'eau qui coule et qui tâchent
d'évoquer la diversité de la vie et la
façon dont les êtres plus ou moins
activement ou passivement accepte la vie
avant vous sembliez fuir les honneurs il
semble que vous ayez changé et
maintenant c'est moi il ya un moment où
les honneurs vous rattrape
on a beau courir merveilleuse réponse
nous revenons aux sports ce genre
grandsir paraplégique a battu à tours au
cours des jeux prennent un pic des
handicapés le record du monde des poids
et haltères catégorie poids moyens elle
a soulevé 215 kg de 115 kg pour un
paraplégique
cela semble fabuleux demain les cours
sont dus à chantilly chez les princes de
condé comme disent les turfistes un peu
snob
je rappellerai en tout cas que
l'hippodrome appartient à l'institut de
france
c'est le grand jour c'est le prix du
jockey club qui doit désigner le
meilleur poulain de l'année personne ne
se détache vraiment plusieurs chevaux
peuvent gagner pierrette brès n'a pas
une tâche facile pour vous livrer son
pronostic
mais devant la vue d'autres quinze
concurrents seulement prendront le
départ du prix du jockey-club ils
représentent l'élite ce qu'il ya de
meilleur parmi les poulains âgés de 3
ans le vainqueur de cette grande épreuve
classique deviendra le chef de file de
cette génération
quelques favoris comme providentiel
chacun pour belge aux arguments se sont
jusqu'à présent entre battu aussi il
faut s'attendre à une lutte sévère qui
pourrait profiter à un outsider comme
par exemple dans l d'eau que l'on voit
travailler sur cette même piste du
jockey club à chantilly
en compagnie de police man mais non elle
doit est assez froid le matin il finit
deuxième
je prendrai
dans de chauds qui participent au judo
club cette année et moi je m'entends
aldo s'est passé le travail la semaine
très bien très bien à part que dans le
dos d'un cheval qui le matin s'emploie
pas trop ton chat le froid ce qui donne
des avantages pour l'après midi c'est
que ils sont pas un petit peu dans ses
galons caisse qui gagne le travail la
semaine police mashaal plus généreux
quand même policeman le matin mais mon
favori pour moi c'est parce qu'il ya des
choses qui se détache tout
particulièrement à part providentiel oui
providentiel seulement c'est un cheval
qui aurait une chance et un choix qui
est lutter sur kinect de la course
j'aime bien ardue membres un cheval un
peu malheureux mais j'aime bien je
l'encouragé aussi deux jours vous aller
surveiller pendant tout un temps plutôt
arguments arguments le voici monté par
jeu son jockey jean claude de saint
gilles et beige taupe ma roue il fait
ici un excellent travail sans forcer
outre mesure
il laisse ses leaders à deux longueurs
derrière lui
satisfaite du galop d'arguments pour ne
rien vous cacher oui m'enfin faisait il
subit pas de galoper le mardi pour
galoper le dimanche 3 2 c'est important
enfin c'est déjà une très bonne chose
savoir elle est en forme et j'espère de
tout mon coeur je ne serai pas pouvoir
être à l'arrivée dans les deux premiers
même peut-être premières et enfin voici
le galop 2 belge au récent vainqueur du
prix du pain il prouve ici qu'il est
toujours au maximum de sa forme en
laissant sur place ses compagnons
d'écurie
alors là la sélection que j'ai préparé
pour vous maudore l'un des poulains les
plus en vue sur la base de ce tiercé car
il vient de gagner le prix hocquart à
l'issue d'une formidable fin de course
providentiel a été décevant dans ce même
prix au cas mais ce fut la seule fausse
note son brillant palmarès argument
vient d'échouer à une demi longueur de
belges ou dans le prix du pain mais son
dernier travail vous l'avez vu m'a
convaincu
chaque app pour en crin pour lui
seulement que la distance de soi trop
longue de 1400 mètres belge au a réalisé
un petit exploit en enlevant le prix du
pain il peut récidiver movie fiq est un
outsider sérieux et dragons auraient été
très dangereux en terrain lourd mais sur
sa classe je lui laisse tout de ma
confiance
alors ces chevaux porteront les numéros
14 5 11 1 de natixis
la finale de la coupe de france de
football se dispute en ce moment même au
parc des princes paris je vous rappelle
que le match oppose monaco à une équipe
de deuxième division
voici un point rapide de la situation à
daniel kazan et bien il y à moins d'une
demi heure que l'on jouait le des
équipes sont à égalité alors que c'est
monaco ici à gauche qui a ouvert le
score à la 6e minute à la suite de ce
débordement de aimons un centre que
d'alger reprend et malheureusement un
défenseur orléanais dévie le ballon dans
son propre but cela fait 1 0 pour monaco
6 minutes de jeu seulement
et l'on pense à ce moment là que mon
apport va dévorer ce petit club de
deuxième division
revoici ce lieu au ralenti avec le
centre daymond le tir de dalles j'ai
dévié donc par défenseur mais à la 22e
minute
à la 22e minute orléans a égalisé de
fort belle manière par son ailier
m'arrête et donc à moins d'une demi
heure de jeu
on en est à 1 but partout
la météo pour demain des pyrénées aux
régions méditerranéennes et aux alpes
ainsi que dans l'extrême-nord
les nuages sont assez abondants et
accompagner d'ondés localement orageuses
sur le reste du pays après une matinée
fraîche et localement brumeuse
le temps sera bien ensoleillé malgré les
nuages passagers lundi l'émission
question de temps de jean pierre
elkabbach et louis berio se présente
sous la forme d'une demande aux visions
diffusée en direct du centre pompidou
avec un reportage de georges leclercq et
en collaboration avec les télévisions
d'italie de belgique de jordanie de
yougoslavie technique qu'une telle
émission implique en fin de soirée c'est
gérard holtz qui vous donnera les
dernières informations de la journée
nous nous trouvons si vous ne vous les
1,6 demain deux fois bonsoir